[Music]
danny meyer is one of the world's most
famous restaurateurs
a leader in the business of hospitality
he is also the man who blessed us with
shake shack
danny was born in st louis missouri in
his childhood was different way more
sophisticated than most
his book reveals a life of privilege and
mature taste buds
enjoying quacked crab as he pronounced
it when he was a kid
his parents both came from privileged
and well-to-do families
the company his paternal grandfather
built was sold for 20 million dollars in
today's equivalent nearly a quarter of a
billion dollars
so danny might have been born with a
silver spoon but thankfully he used that
spoon to serve us some
really delicious food danny's father was
a consultant for an airline
as a child of a consultant danny ate up
those perks which included 44
round-trip flights to europe he writes
throughout my college years i could not
afford not to fly pan am to italy for
any long weekend
i would just call my dad and he'd hand
write a 44
ticket as much as he loved traveling and
experimenting with different cuisines
he didn't yet follow that passion for
the food and beverage industry
after he graduated college he moved to
chicago
briefly working at a public news station
then as a local coordinator for a
presidential
campaign after that he decided to move
to the big apple
with grandpa irving's help he got a
sales job working for a company that
made anti-shoplifting labels and devices
and was their leading salesman for
several years but he didn't want that as
a career
so he studied for the lsats but the
night before he took the lsats he had an
epiphany went out to dinner with a few
family members
he decided to abandon the plan to study
law and follow his dream of owning a
restaurant
and so he got into the industry working
as a daytime assistant manager at pesca
in new york city
nearly two years later at the age of 27
he was running his first restaurant
union square cafe
then his second and third
and so on and so on and of course we
can't forget that little hot dog stand
in madison square park
you know the one that turned into shake
shack which ipo'd in 2015.
his new york times bestseller setting
the table shares his
enlightened hospitality philosophy of
showing the importance of hospitality
first to his staff
where it then trickles down to guests
community suppliers and investors
through his investment fund enlightened
hospitality investments
he invests in startups like gold belly
joe coffey company
rezzy and clear today danny meyer runs
union square hospitality group which
encompasses his collection of
restaurants and other hospitality
related businesses
his restaurants have earned some of the
most coveted awards and recognition in
the industry today
you